your definition of weirdo kendrick is a
weirdo i don't think he's a weirdo
because i know kendrick and i know he's
just wait i'm i'm i understand what you
were saying i don't know kenji
you replied to the play style
establishment i'm talking about style
yeah we've established that
right so
just see when you know somebody more
press whatever but back to the to the to
the jolly bad [ __ ]
when you seen them like i said what i
said i'm break i'm lyrical with it i'm
breaking them down and since they said a
partner of his he brought other people
into it it wasn't just him going hr he
brought up
somebody from his group so more records
in troy okay so now it's open season or
anybody from your group here or going
you feel me that's what happened
they they open pandora's box and then
chop it whoa whoa you went too far don't
play with me did anyone around you hear
that and try to convince you to take it
out
um
they
the video they was like yo come on the
video was nuts because i did the video
on the roof yeah yeah but i mean like i
said look all these [ __ ] you
got on your wall you got them on your
wall tupac hit him up come on take if
you feel away about it if you're not
standing on how troy have went about his
business then you need to take tupac
over your wall or else you'll be in the
house that was a more serious situation
what are you talking about serious to
who seriousness is objective
seriously if somebody slaps you in your
face you don't have to respond to them
with a punch you i've seen people get
slapped like all the cops oh no i've
seen people get started damn what's
wrong with this guy he's crazy
yeah i mean
so everything you say i'm only speaking
with facts listen nobody can tell nobody
can tell anyone how to react to
something right you have your own that
was more serious and if i'm this i just
i'm just i'm just telling you the
perception of i'm not telling you
you like my opinions because i'm on the
bootleg kev podcast i don't know man i
think
i'm not on the perception i think
um
at that time
to me it felt unnecessary it felt over
the top
for at the moment like
new york we always hear about how
atlanta moves together
you know why can't new york and la move
together like atlanta does and at that
time
it felt like
you were you would like
carved out troy island
and you were just standing on your
island in new york when i said that you
mean yeah and just in general i just
feel like you i feel like you were i
mean i knew you at the you know i know
you so like i was very close to your
situation right um
and so i would like you know i'd be like
yeah well [ __ ] it seems like a lot of
people are rooting against you
as opposed to rooting for you and i
think that that was because of some of
the things you would say some of and
that's just you being you just being
it's just me being a real person i am on
troya violin because i i'm self-made and
self-paid nobody put me on and brought
me up i had 100
from the ground up
relationships i meet i call it dj's like
i used to call you everybody
very much tattooed
labels
but with these two situations that you
bringing up
who started them they were all reactions
i didn't and that's important that's
important no one can tell any individual
how to react to something but i'm asking
do you do do you agree it was all
i mean how did we bash it was it was it
a reaction who i i agree that you
reacted you went through the first shot
i mean based on
the
yeah yeah bro listen it's been so long
yeah but so yeah so yeah so i do
remember that line that joey dropped so
that's him throwing a shot at me and so
you you're that was your reaction to
someone who threw a shot at you first
because you had never thrown a shot at
him prior to that correct directly no i
don't throw i don't be going around
throwing shots i'll be focused on me i'm
not worried about what another man doing
i'm focused on so we've established that
you reacted to joey and you reacted to
the control freestyle and the kendrick
thing i just think people were like what
the [ __ ] but i think people it wasn't it
wasn't disrespectful yeah he wasn't he
wasn't disrespecting you but at that
time i just don't think not about this
thing wasn't as big of a big deal like i
just think it was just like it wasn't at
all but it was just like how how this
[ __ ] appeared you know what i mean
that's why it wasn't a big deal that's
why i just do it one line in here i'm
just representing i'm i'm standing up
for my city i didn't know for sure for
my city no
it wasn't a big it wasn't a big it
wasn't personal um that other [ __ ] was
personal i i i i see that i should
personally at that time this person i
don't really give a [ __ ] now